five tremendously talented actors were  nominated by their peers for their  stunning performances and supporting  roles here they are Alan Alda in the  Aviator Thomas Haden Church in sideways  Jamie Foxx in collateral  Morgan Freeman in Million Dollar Baby  Clive Owen in closer  and the Oscar goes to Morgan Freeman  this is the first Academy Award in  fourth nomination for Morgan Freeman he  was previously  street smart and Driving Miss Daisy and  Shawshank Redemption  I want to thank everybody and anybody  who ever had anything at all to do with  the making of this picture but I  especially want to thank Clint Eastwood  for giving me the opportunity to work  with him again and to work with Hilary  Swank this was a labor of love and I  thank the Academy I thank you so very  much